foreign
[Music]
welcome to a very important episode of
careful boys
and today we're going to talk about who
are some future guests you would like to
have on the show I'll go first salt
Poppy oh I love him how about Big Ben
tag him please he's funny he's not the
stick guy he's not this oh okay not that
good um Filipino dude that guy he's cool
from the UK I believe
that he's really funny but he's been
knocking [__] it's so funny too
because he's all like remember the
recent guy he [__] up he's all like
yeah he's muzzled but muscles don't win
fights yeah he's
cool because he just has like a straight
soft body like he doesn't look athletic
yeah like
like he's making he's making pretty okay
boxers look like they don't even know I
want him to fight Jay Paul it's gonna be
a pretty good fight I think so they were
they were talking about doing a Floyd
Mayweather KSI tag team match versus
Manny Pacquiao and saw poppy whoa that's
good marketing right there that's a
really good marketing are we out on the
Floyd thing yet like here in Floyd's
gonna fight is just the most boring
thing you could ever [__] say he
still can watch it though he's picking
up I don't think anyone's watching it in
the States but he's picking up checks
all across the the world yeah and just
by doing these little exhibitions so he
gave barbell Brigade stuff too salt
puppy he was yeah that's so cool people
sent it to the JK then they're like yo
is he could he come on JK because he's
wearing barbell he's connected so that's
all cool man yeah that's still awesome
yeah maybe some of his uh
employee sent it to him or something
I saw poppy on here I talked to him here
and there oh you do yeah yeah he's
really cool he grew up on us he brought
us about JK on David oh dude say that
earlier what bring him on yeah we're
gonna talk about two minutes about this
camera
yeah you're like you're like yeah
everybody tag him but you're like
already in direct communication yeah
like yeah he grew up on JK like we
raised him that's true yeah and it's
like oh yeah you could get him on the
show then what the [__] are you talking
about yeah I forgot he's the man I think
anybody else have any I'm not I am
autistic so yeah okay is a very good
what would you want Nick
I don't know man it would be nice to
have Jackson wangan I think yeah Jackson
wait if only we knew someone that knew
Jackson Wang well we know somebody who
acts like he knows him but I don't know
oh who's that Ryan dude I actually know
someone that always has him on his
podcast and he's really close to us oh
wait oh I was thinking about you oh word
oh wait oh I think I was thinking about
Anthony too dude my stock is hella high
now all right so who else
he's only looking at me dude
um I don't have Bart's mom
to be honest the time traveler first my
mom for reals to be honest my mom I'd be
so down dude bring her up bring it on
L.A again
Anthony knows her you have a hot seat
with Bart's mom I we gotta do it I think
I need to mentally prepare myself
because
I don't know she's just so much trauma
between me and her what if she's just
here one of those days you're not here
but you hanging
hang with him
yeah but on camera you're just gonna be
more annoyed maybe this will bring you
guys together because we'll be able to
say things that maybe you always wanted
to say like like who would you [__] your
mom or your dad oh [__] I don't think so
who's your [__] your son or your son
laughs
if you do a really good one because
she'd be stuck she'd have to say she
doesn't work your son or your ex-husband
oh that's good it's the ultimate
gaslighter
so if you can resist her Hocus Pocus
skills yeah it's then go ahead I don't
know if we'll be able to though I hope
we all turn on each other all right
honestly I hope she brings [__] bread
that she makes dude she sits in there
we need to have taika back taika
yeah as he gets older it's like good to
like at least once a year to see like
the I'll be checking with taika dude
that would be great I would like to get
Michelle yawan that would be amazing
[__] cool [__] why though oh my
goodness why would she come here I don't
know why she would come she's at the top
of her game right now there's no way
every game I grew up watching her and it
would just be cool to kind of see like
the most like prominent Asian person
that will be cool to be able to talk to
her but I feel like people come here and
their careers get ruined right you know
who I did uh I slide I slid into a DM uh
just the other day to see if we can go
on the podcast it was kihu Quan oh cool
oh really yeah of course you didn't
check it though not yet who's that
uh he's the dude that was the Short
Round oh Short Round yeah oh yeah Short
Round yeah
hey data so uh they said it they [__]
said it when he won when he when he
spoke his name was he didn't know who he
was by his name the Oscars
from Indiana Jones a surrounding [__]
they were saying sure you know what I
thought all right they made him wear a
hat so you know he was Short Round and
end data right yeah so because he was
the same kid on [__] Goonies yeah so
I thought that was his stereotypical
accent that in the 90s they made him do
and then when he did the speech I was
like holy [__] that's how that's how he
speaks oh you never saw everything
everywhere all at once
okay it was Korean Cinema's [__]
crushing it right now and every I watch
a lot of cream this one won like every
[__] Oscar and this picture and
everything like that but this one was
good it was a I was a movie about math
was it pretty good I'm already hooked
tell me more movie about math
Jamie Foxx wow Jamie Foxx damn you're
really shooting stars well you're asking
the Joe Biden on here dude
hey we were this explosive getting
Andrew Yang yeah it was very close we're
always very close to getting a [__]
killer and then they watch the channel
and then go
[Laughter]
you know so David recently was you know
he went to one of those
um mixers right and all those people
Asian American Cinema they're all you
know they're all bare like gold house
like those things all yeah all the all
the guys and then so
you know very David's like outspoken
about everything which is why we can't
get certain guests on here right yes
yeah but they all went up to him and
said oh you know on a low like we all
love the [__] you guys say because
that's how we really feel but we can't
say it and then do you remember the
names he was like then why the [__] I
know he's like why the [__] are you
supporting the people on Twitter and all
that [__] like because they want to have
a career who are censoring you we're
keeping you from they gotta play the
game because we care about our families
and communities right they want a career
and then and then David was like and and
it was like those actors in everything
everywhere like all of them they watch
JK they like were I think we're their
guilty pleasure I think Michelle this is
time on Michelle yo Michelle
come down send me a DM I'll get you here
Short Round oh we'll get you some Waba
Grill for lunch because it's gonna be a
good time however way you want it I love
you because the way I see it is like
it's kind of like our politician friends
that like hit DMS on the side like let
us know on the side like how they like
that [__] because they they can't say a
lot of the stuff that we say you like
that [__] I can't say any of it
well okay think about it like all those
guys in Hollywood I don't think they're
[__] I just think that they have a
lot they have like their lives on the
line
they can't say the stuff that we can say
because like I've constructed my life to
specifically be a low life
you're born in it there's nothing on the
line bro like who you're meant to be
what yeah I'm not gonna lose my life
because of the way I speak and I can I
rather speak my mind and be broke than
be [__] A Millionaire and just shut
the [__] up I have to talk I don't know
if I share that sentiment but that's how
we feel about it I respect you you know
what I respect you you're in this ditch
with me I am in the distance too bad
we're all Associated enough Yeah by
association yeah [__] it let's be
pouring loud baby you're in the shot
that they're gonna use for the article
so it's when they're talking about Jake
from the thumbnail yeah you're a lot of
thumbnails you're on The Daily Mail
basically
kiss your career goodbye
I bet you got some good ones you know a
lot of people so on here you want Jim
man for BTS
like who's a realistic person that would
probably be that would do well on this
that would like be a good phone it would
be fun yeah it might be interesting to
bring like Andy Lee uh um and his
brother or whatever the day oh yeah yeah
because you did the martial arts and
stuff yeah oh yeah they grew up on us
too but they don't talk to me anymore
damn I'm sorry dude maybe they're just
maybe they just got to that level where
same thing it's like hey I don't want to
be in the ditch
yeah it's probably it took so much work
to get out it seems like there's a
common theme yeah a little bit I feel
like when people aren't really in
Hollywood and then they're just like I
love YouTube right and it's my dream to
be a YouTuber but when they can skip
that and go straight to the real Fame
[__] they're like no going back there's
no their PR agent is like whatever you
do do not [__] go anywhere close to
those JK guys you know does that make
sense yeah yeah I like being pulled
inside the party like hey bro come here
like oh my God you're my guilty pleasure
like I watch you when there's nobody
around and like it's cool it's okay to
watch you you guys are like porn yeah
yeah
like when my when like if my wife comes
in the room like I pretend like I'm
watching porn and I throw Jakey in
another window today's video is brought
to you by Sunday you know what I've been
noticing uh as I get older I've been
valuing the greens in my life you know
there's that one study the more greens
you see with the eyeballs the healthier
you are because just like around you so
if you get Sunday you can help improve
your lawn which will make you feel
really good because you got life all
around you because you don't want to
spend all day trying to take care of
your lawn yeah how come why do you think
grass should be greener always on the
other side no no it should be greener on
this side and we're going to spray this
beautiful fertilizer that they can
actually create for your home's needs
it's pretty awesome and you can get one
right here depending on the type of
fertilizer you need
and it's super easy to use you get this
pouch right here you connect this over
here and then you get a hose on the
other side put that in and get ready to
spray so you can tell your grandparents
deal yo you could stop [__] on the
lawn get that get your hepatitis ass out
of here you got no harsh chemicals you
got all the good stuff so you put that
in there it's all the ingredients that
you care about and look at this bottle 5
000 square feet it's almost size of a
basketball court yep that's a lot Yep
this one almost the size of a basketball
if you're super rich you get two of them
but I feel like most people just need
one and then what's that one it's
this one is long Kickstart yeah it's for
lawn Improvement and this one is for
Drought season for People Like Us in
Vegas yep Californians well these days
California probably not so much but
after this year probably gonna go right
back to the drought anyway right back to
go to getsunday.com off the Record so
enter your address to get a customized
plan made just for your lawn no trips to
the store or hauling heavy bags since
they ship straight to your home Sunday
is easy and affordable some lawn care
services cost more than 1500 a year but
sun is full season plans start at just
109 bucks and Sunday is offering all
listeners that's you guys 20 off a full
season plan starts at just 109 and for a
limited time Sunday is offering our
listeners 50 off your first box so you
can get started today for as little as
55 dollars when you go to getsunday.com
off the Record at checkout that's 50 off
your first box at get monday.com off the
record I slammed my laptop shut do we
ever get a chance to figure out if we
can reach out to that dude who stopped
the [__] gunman in Monterey Park I
tried and I got lazy oh word that makes
it okay how far did you get I messaged
no I found his Facebook and I didn't
message him remember what happened I was
asking you guys if you could message him
because I sent the message and it came
back as you can't send it oh yeah and
then I was like why and then that was it
I think it was a funny moment here
yesterday that I want to talk about
where um Bart and Joe were actually
looking at a piece of a piece of
furniture in here and then Anthony and
Ryan who've been trying to change the
office for like I don't know [__] two
years now they're like oh my God it's
like the bosses actually care right now
it was like a really cool moment because
they are huddled over and figuring out
what things do we not need we were like
look at what's happening
we don't need a [__] film right now
just let him do their thing don't say
anything shut up
let it happen and then they're both like
talking like apes like oh yeah we can
change this move that one and these boys
just had hope in their eyes
dangerous thing you can give somebody
so who's the person I want Twan on is he
alive
he does pairs by night bro hell yeah I
think has blue is too big for us now no
we can't get hospital really white yes
he's everywhere he's probably the most
famous person it's Harum he's not gonna
come he gets a sock everyone in the face
I know I legitimately think though we
could get Mike Tyson somehow yeah I
would love myself I was this close
number one right now you were this close
how we're always this close though right
yeah my friends produced his show at the
where he films all that stuff oh and
then um just tell him we got mushrooms
and weeds I was like come over here I
was like
why don't you hook a homie up and bring
him over here
and then he he didn't talk to me for
like a month yeah yeah and he goes hey
I'm opening up a lunch truck you want to
come by and I'm like bring Mike Tyson
first and he didn't talk to me for like
two months and then he's like he's like
hey I got this new product you want to
promote for me I was like bring Mike
Tyson and he can talk to me for another
month for four months yeah but I'll get
there it'll I think one day we'll get
there you're good at building
relationships I am yeah no no no we've
been friends for a while you're chipping
away You're Gonna use that favor one day
yeah yeah we're gonna get Mike Tyson I
think I believe that yeah
um I don't know I don't know how much
that's gonna happen anyone else before I
I wanted to name a bunch of people but
now I'm embarrassed to say because
they'll see it and go oh yeah I probably
shouldn't come on this show really no by
the way that's true no no at that point
then [__] it just say their name just
say it so then they go no I come on the
show yeah well maybe we can try to maybe
we can try to Rebrand like I don't know
this isn't a ditch I know I'm trying
because I know that I know there's
people that would want to come and they
just wanted us to ask too sometimes yeah
maybe don't say jk just say you come to
a careful boy shoot and then they get
tricked when they show up when they show
up yeah
lock the door
no this is this is a good place to be
this is a very very good place I love
every time we've had a guest here and
you can tell that they're like oh we're
gonna keep going for a while huh
and that's when I know that they're
never ever ever coming back
I think they're used to showing up and
speaking for an hour and going home we
make people work hard right you're here
for [__] six hours talking this is no
[__] [__] around Place dude
we're feeding you some Hainan chicken so
shut the [__] up you know what other
places dude we got a whole snack closet
we don't have a snack bar we have
[__] 10 rows we got light coming
through the holes in the ceiling dude we
got [__] these cool chips man chips
tired in four days yeah
if I had my mother over here I'd be like
hey Mom you should probably use a
painter's bucket outside oh yeah
speaking of which the crunchy uh Bros
guy uh crunch Brothers my twin yeah
I'd love to have them on him and his son
yeah and I and I could be his his second
son I can sit next to him and we could
all look at this look at your father I
would love to get your wife as well dude
I think I could get no Tiff would never
come on the show really he's like being
that public eye I just want her to roast
you all day yeah if we did the CIA
[__] pixelation [__] would she come
on with a deep voice I think I think
there's a way we could do that because
she is really funny at dunking on me
she's really good she's really good at
she's really good at embarrassing me and
I think you guys would have a lot of fun
with that Dynamic yeah I'm wearing her
down every day okay dunking on you is
just not that fun for us so it'd be fun
to see somebody who's good at it yeah
really good who knows all the other
stuff because he deflects so hard he
doesn't give us anything to work on yeah
that's his whole plan give you guys a
lot for you guys to dunk up no it's not
that fun it's not personal enough like
when we dunk on you you're laughing and
[__] we don't dunk on this guy right
we're all alley-oop and [__] scores
like that running the score up and
running the [__] clocked out and [__]
on this guy you know there's so much joy
in the room yeah everyone's like what's
up everyone this togetherness love the
pile on as well yeah great memories he's
got a point there Nick you're not as fun
that's why we do it right there that
face right there hey you know what dude
I'll be more of a stranger money making
baby yeah and change I'll change and I
won't laugh so if you say something to
me I'm gonna [__] get real mad
wow yeah just to sell it no that's not
so Anthony gets off the hook for a
little bit okay
um oh they're um the fans always had
this really funny idea of replacing each
of us with our partners and just cold
starting a that's a great idea that
would be really great for us it's
probably such a [__] video though why
insane about your partner yeah dude like
they have the same chemistry that we've
all put into each other no but it's the
playing on the awkwardness I think smack
would be really good at that she's also
a professional Entertainer I know that's
why yeah some of them are ladies are not
like who's
how dare you say that about yourself
my wife is what if the dynamic is
exactly the same like Tiff is just
deflecting
is just getting dumped off
by Nikki specifically Nikki's going ham
on neither Anita has no answers for
Nikki
that'd be even better though if like if
they were trying to beat us that would
be how well can they mimic us yeah but
then between takes Nina and Nikki are
doing shots back there [__] hugging
it out doing shots
that would be a good show they're just
acting like us yeah that would be pretty
fun Nikki's getting Nina into some
crypto that goes to [__] zero
[Laughter]
she's talking about feudal Japan
Geo's nose is bleeding
that would be crazy that would be best
that's their dream that would be like a
very special thing if we did that that's
that's the that's the two million two
million subscribers how about that
you'll start saying really toxic things
and troubling things troubling toxic
things I would say a straight face no
laughing yeah yeah while eating
everything yeah it feels like I think
child molester should be molested
by children
I think the that is a good two million
goal that would be huh yeah I think so
I could probably get smacked to do that
one she'd be down that would be a fun
time dude we should have them all talk
about guns because I don't think any of
them
your topic is gun control all right let
me close the door
we would have to go in there we can't
hear it hear all our faces make sure you
pass you passionately defend it yeah
yeah you know all of our viewpoints you
know we all have a group mind yeah we
don't yeah we do not disagree
Nina's gonna come on here dunk on me too
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the girls ask you specifically to come
in they just all dunk on you the whole
[__] time
[Laughter]
sometimes the magic of JK though it's
the inside jokes that more that that are
sometimes way better than having a uh
interesting guest on it I agree because
like if you even see in our views too
even from the past like some of the
craziest moments and Views happen from
the moments that just happen from us in
the group not because we had a viral
guest or whatever because like we've had
guests that had millions of like Subs on
their Channel
they just don't pull views we've had
guests that are like 10 000 subs or no
YouTube channel that are getting
millions of views because just the topic
was amazing the story was amazing the
conversation what happens in this room
is what's amazing so it's like I think
the magic really I don't know I would
only want guests that are extremely
interesting I wouldn't give a [__] about
like where they are like Southwest uh
soft white underbelly I thought I think
like getting people that are like oh
[__] you live that life and interviewing
them yeah interesting
I just pull them in for a video that's
kind of tight that's a tight idea that's
a great idea there's also too sitting in
that chair is a [__] tough seat bro
especially for the first time you walk
in here and you don't know any of us
right that's why you've never done it
have I I've sat there before you've been
here before I couldn't handle it your
boy was sweating was I sweating big
moment he just giggled away oh this
chair's a little too big for you then I
feel like the first three months of Nick
at JK his job was the giggler oh my God
I just thought it was fun I was having a
good time yeah I mean that's me too when
I first came I was just laughing at
everything he laughed how about that
yeah not anymore I don't [__] until
he got shut down for bullying jokes yeah
that's true huh
We Don't Billy over here I guess we
[__] do are you out of your mind
Bully's made us dude now we're passing
it down I owe my bullies alive me too
the rage and um resentment that I have
that's it's brought me to where I am
today because I wanted to be successful
and laugh at their [__] face for
having a miserable life yeah I'll thank
you guys later hey you take all of us
later
[Music]
foreign